daily mail says new york high school
under fire
after teacher handed out cartoon which
compares cops to the kkk
and slave owners on first day of class
and i saw this story and i thought to
myself look
look at this image so first you have
what looks like a colonial guy
he says i and then there's a black man
on the ground and each and every one i
can't i can't wait it's like i ca
i i can't i i can't breathe
and then the last one is the cop
kneeling on a dude's neck
and it just does not represent
historical context
at all and so it's just one example of
grade school indoctrination so let's
we'll read this story and then i'll show
you some of the searches because you can
find this at every school basically
they say a school in westchester has
come under fire after a teacher handed
out an image to students about the black
lives matter movement
comparing modern day cops to slave
owners and the ku klux klan
west lake high school educator chris
christopher moreno
gave his 11th graders a handout on
september 8th on the first day of
classes
the handout included a five frame
cartoon panel titled george floyd
each panel showing a white man kneeling
on the neck of a black man from
different historical periods
in the first frame a pirate is shown
kneeling a a pirate
let's see a pirate kneeling on a black
man in chains having been captured
i think that's supposed to be just like
a colonial slave trader and you know
call him a pirate probably had
governmental authority to do do the
things he's doing
let me go and explain this i showed you
the picture already but uh but yeah so
for those that are listening it's what
looks like a colonial slave trader
followed by a plantation owner
followed by a klansman and then just the
cop
and there's a sign saying white only and
then finally what looks like supposed to
be chauvin and george floyd
they say west lake mother anya pattern
nostro told the new york post my
daughter showed me the paper i said what
is this you've got to be kidding me
the cartoon compares the police to the
clan it's an attack on the police
pattern nostro said that she immediately
sent letters
protesting the cartoon to mount pleasant
school district superintendent kurt
coates and westlake principal keith
schenker whose school is in the district
enough is enough to pedernastro said to
the post
this cartoon is disturbing we have to
respect the men in blue who protect us
out of the mom of two a native of poland
wow interesting
we don't need a teacher brainwashing my
kids i'll teach my kids about what's
right and what's wrong
her daughter nicole said that she was
troubled by the cartoon included in
moreno's lessons plan calling it
disgusting
for comparing the police to all the
terrible people in history it wasn't
fair
it wasn't right the high school student
said she had since been bullied on
social media
since she made the controversial lesson
plan public and has been called a racist
oh wow well that's it shut her down
she's a racist you know so she wins
i mean is there any hair so she's out is
there any sense of whether this is part
of the curriculum
because to me there should be maybe some
sort of
stop gap some some process of knowing
what belongs
in schools or are these teachers just
going out and finding cartoons online
and just you know on twitter and memes
and they're just putting in their
classroom because
i can't to see any any school board
approving something like this
i don't think they have yeah i don't
think it's part of the curriculum
although there was a leaked school
curriculum
that was just basically all social
justice activism
was not even teaching kids anything i
don't know i don't know why parents are
still putting their kids in these places
man
it's hard to know yeah how much it's if
it's in the curriculum how much the
ideology has seeped in where this is
just what's being offered
by these institutions or if this is just
like rogue teachers
just i mean bringing their politics in
the classroom or just uh it's probably a
marriage of both
it's probably that but who's who's going
to speak up against him you're not a
bigot are you
well you you are right you you left
academia i have been accused
you're not but they say you are because
they say that about everybody i mean to
me this is the critical race
cartoon version of things like the
gender-bred person and the gender
unicorn
gender-bred person yeah you've probably
seen those before yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's again it's all part of this
like critical
theory assessment of how how power
dynamics are playing in society in
different areas this is the critical
race version of it
and then you go with the gender gender
studies version there's like the
colonial version of it
and right right manifest themselves in
weird cartoons like this that we're
teaching our children apparently
would you put your kids in the school
you know i used to be
a pretty strong proponent of public
education and i used to be very
much against uh voucher programs and
this was mainly because i didn't want
students to be you know not taught
evolution or taught creationism and
intelligent design but over the last
three years i've done a complete 180 i'm
now
100 percent vouchers i don't think i'd
want to send my kids a 500. that's
crazy it's crazy i it's totally off
subject but i was just talking about
earlier today
i bought a bunch of guns think about how
crazy left has gone
to where you used to be against the
voucher program for school choice
i used beginning this year i was like no
guns in my house
and now like a combination of factors
has like pushed us both
like just on the other side of these
things i will march for vouchers now
you will march i mean i have an
evolutionary biology background of a phd
in evolutionary biology
i don't want creationism intelligent
design in schools but frankly i'd rather
have my students
at a private school teaching religious
notions of creationism intelligent
design
as long as they're not teaching a lot of
this wokeness i'd i'd prefer
an indoctrination into creationism than
into you know this this critical theory
nonsense but why is that what you do
think
the critical race there is more
dangerous i do i mean
i used to argue with intelligent design
people and
at least they're up for an argument at
least they're presenting some sort of
evidence
that i think is bad evidence but they're
at least willing to engage with you in a
public sphere they at least think
the outside world exists as you know we
see it to some degree and they'll use
they'll use certain facts i think
they're used bad facts to make a case
for themselves
but then when you talk to these critical
theorist people they don't even think
that facts are something that
is real they think these are all social
constructions so there's just no
there's no objection there's no
foundation we're not starting from the
same same place to have an argument
they're starting from
a place where knowledge is socially
constructed white western
everything this is really interesting so
when i talk to them it's it's not just a
clash of ideas it's a it's a world of
views that are diametrically opposed in
every single way
trying to figure things out and there's
just they don't translate but i wonder
if
if it's actually that they have
political views or they're just
your enemy you know what i mean like
they're emotionally invested in opposing
the other
and so the re so here's what i'm saying
you go to a creationist
and they'll say here's why i believe in
creation and they'll try
and find evidence to support that
because they understand the concept of
evidence exists
like you said bad evidence for sure and
at some point
a lot of times they'll get down to like
well i just believe it on faith but
right right there's some that are sort
of it's in the bible
there is a movement of just sort of like
a justified faith thing where they try
to
ground it all unreasonable evidence and
i'm i'm happy talking to those people
well so so here's here's what i'm trying
to say if you go to these critical race
theory people
they'll say whatever they have to say at
any given moment to make it make sense
even if it contradicts what they said 10
seconds ago
exactly yeah but that speak so i'm
wondering if it's really about
an actual ideology or if they're kind of
making it up as they go along they're
basically just
saying you're a bad guy and so no matter
what you say i oppose
you know what i mean like they don't
actually belie like
let me i'll put it this way like yes
there are some
tenets of what they believe in but it's
only because
they've been espoused enough but it
comes to a point where
if you if you say okay well the evidence
doesn't suggest to this and their their
response is
you believe in evidence they're clearly
just contrarian
yeah well so they're diametrically
opposed to like stable notions
of reality and so when you try to like
drill them drill down on any certain
aspect
their main tactic is going to be to just
problematize it to try to just shift the
floor out from under your feet
a lot of their tactics if you read some
of their papers and stuff
they'll take some some concept and then
they'll
deconstruct it in a million pieces and
then their ultimate conclusion at the
end of the day is almost entirely
well there's not much to conclude here
it's just they just you know they just
break
binaries break any sort of boundaries
blur the distinctions between borders
on any concept and that's just sort of
their that's how that's how it works
they don't want this stable
like two plus two is five that's you
know a good example of
wow there's so much of this stuff it's
everywhere yeah it's everything yeah and
it's crazy uh well
i want to say because we're definitely
talking about trump banning the stuff in
the government
but i want to show you this because this
is a story from just last month
u.s schools are changing their
curriculum in response to black lives
matter as survey finds 81
of teachers support the movement 81
now now i gotta say if if all of the
teachers believe this
why should i think you're correct
well i'm half kidding but yeah it's it
needs to be
broken down into what's meant by black
lives matter and the
the language game they play where it can
be both a movement
an ideology a statement of of clear fact
that black lives do in fact matter
and that's why it's one of the best
slogans i can imagine because no one
would be against
saying black lives matter as a general
statement of what's true about
the value of life uh and so but they can
they can change the meaning in any
context they want to
to sort of get what they want get their
results yeah no one's going to be
standing up in a group
uh you know in a school setting where
they're trying to have
uh their people are going to be voting
on whether or not the curriculum gets
based on black lives matter something no
one's going to be the one guy standing
up to say i'm actually against
black lives matter because you'll just
be harangued out of the room yeah
they'll say what do you
what do you think they don't matter
what's wrong with you not a good look
it's a semantic
manipulation but here's the important
factor if 81
of teachers agree with the movement and
we we have an endless number of schools
that have adopted the curriculum
won't it just be that the next the next
generation these young kids in grade
school are going to grow up
indoctrinated into that world view
and you are going to be a creepy weirdo
who doesn't understand reality
i'm sure there's a lot of people saying
that right now that i'm the creepy
weirdo
yeah i try to think if you know if you
have things like intelligent design what
if
81 of teachers were pro that you know we
have to have
some notion of what can be taught in
schools
that can't just be based on do most
teachers believe in this thing you need
to have something that's
based in evidence something that's
factually able to be argued from first
principles like evolutionary biology
over creationism intelligent design
and what we're getting here with the
black lives matter critical race theory
that's being put in there
is people are bringing their politics to
the table and they're asserting that
this is the only way we can deal about
with
with racial issues they reject the sort
of liberal approach to
um to race and just because people
believe in it
it seems to just be steamrolling ahead
did you hear about that group of people
who want to create a black only city
i did yeah also the michigan state
university they have the um dearborn
is that what that is yeah where they did
the white only thing yeah the white
white only was it a cafe yeah it but
it's it's like it was like a virtual
hangout session they called a cafe which
was really
weird yeah it was yeah it was a remote
it's still
it's even strange it's still really
weird you're gonna be like you know
we're gonna put out a link come hang out
in the zoom chat
if you're white that's that's that's the
logical conclusion to what these
schools are promoting it's it's it's
crazy i i was talking to a friend about
a lot of this stuff
who used to be a normal liberal and now
is like
i hate to say it but i'm like it's it's
it's it's hardcore and itarianism
this is a white woman telling all of her
white friends to form a collective
to take collective racial action for the
betterment of the the poor minorities
who are underprivileged and i'm like
dude you're asserting superiority over
this group in some capacity
and you're arguing you're you're pushing
for white racial collective action
can you look in a mirror for two seconds
like what do you what would you call
that it sounds like racism
it sounds like extra steps yeah yeah
yeah with extra steps
an intense focus on making race the most
important issue is some way going to
make race
less important or make race go away i
don't think that's their plan
what do you think the plan is well i
will say seeing schools
adopt all this stuff seeing schools call
cops like clan members and slave owners
how absolutely psychotic is that slave
trader very very different from a guy
who's trying to stop a mugger from like
beating the crap out of a woman you know
what i mean
not like they always can do that but
they respond to crimes and they file
reports and they
help arrest people lock people up they
do a lot of things i don't like
recently with covet a lot of
unconstitutional law and they just kind
of follow the order
but but you you can call the cops and be
like someone broke in my house and the
cops will rush there
i had someone trying to break in here i
called the cops they came and said you
know we got you whatever you need man we
got your back i'm like man so grateful
these guys are here
so dramatically different from a clan
member
and so so these schools are it's it
seems like
there's there's two there's two visible
goal uh outcomes that are coming from
this the first
is they want to destroy our institutions
right so first you take all these bad
things from history
slave owners clan members and then align
them with police
you want people these people a lot of
these black lives matter activists are
going around saying like police are
hunting
us like i that no that's that's
like paranoid it's not happening and
they claim it is
and then you get these well-to-do
liberals who are pushing the stuff
saying look look they are because they
said so
because their lived experience is more
important than empirical evidence which
they don't believe exists anyway
the end result of changing the
definitions of words
changing the pronunciation of words like
whimx into whimminks
like that's not even how the letter it's
spell it w-o-m-n-x
and we'll talk about women women
spell anyway but they're just basically
deconstructing everything like
you were saying this right they take
everything they strip it they ship it
for parts
and then they leave the parts laying on
the ground they're not rebuilding
anything
so so in the end what happens the
schools teach kids a bunch of nonsense
the kids grow up and have no idea how to
function because instead of learning
math they learned
police are bad so that's that's one
outcome i don't know if their
their intention is to do that or if
their goal is to break everything down
and then once it's completely destroyed
create their socialists you know marxist
utopia or whatever it is they think
i think that's the the second one is
what i think they're mainly doing
because they need the institutions
they don't want to well they want to
destroy them as we know them
well but they want to use them as sort
of their recruitment ground and
their right right they're rhetorical
they want to wear the institutions like
skin suits
after they latch onto the neck of the
institution and suck the the moist juicy
innards of the creature out and then
parasitically take over
and start it's like men in black you
know things like eric weinstein that
talked about them being
sort of uh hermit crabs and we have all
these different
institutions and they have different
shells and we see the shells
remain intact and then some at some
point all the crabs that used to inhabit
them left
and now there's these new crabs in the
masquerading around as the new york
times as
right you know whatever you want they
still have this prestige of having those
shells but
i like i like you like yours i like mine
better you know
the the uh vincent d'onofrio from men in
black
you know the giant the giant centipede
alien
goes inside his skin and then he's like
jerking around all like
sugar water i like that better because
the jerky
like broken motions represent what these
institutions are because i can see that
it's
they're zombies of what they use yeah
for sure because
well uh so so yeah yeah if you if you
were to say that like
like i think what you said eric
weinstein was saying at their shells
well that's assuming they're still
moving around like regular hermit crabs
but they're not
they're they're grotesque weird bugs
that are wearing the skin
and like lurching around and they don't
speak proper english right so
when you see the guy edgar and men in
black and she's like edgar and he's like
sugar water
you're like that's not a normal human
thing to ask for interesting so when
these institutions
are women like yeah womanx yeah they're
not or uh
anymore well the other thing is like
there was a curriculum leak and i talked
about this before
where it asked a math question but
instead of being something about like
the farmer has you know a dozen apples
how many apples you take away blah blah
it was like the police stop you know 1
300 black people
and they only stopped two you know 246
white people what percentage of you know
the stops are black people
and it's like they're injecting this
racialized world
view so so anyway here's the other thing
i think like the first one is maybe
they're like destroying the system
or the outcome is going to be destroyed
system maybe they'll rebuild it
not that they would destroy the
institutions it's the it's the the
innards that are getting ripped to
shreds
like the the core structure and they're
occupying it like some kind of parasitic
alien
the other thing is also in that vein
it's about what their goal is is it
marxism
or is it overt balkanization
racial segregation and white supremacy
that's a good question i think it's
they're just trying to
blur the boundaries between things so
they can sort of assert what they want
to assert
at any given moment it's but i mean
think i think it sounds nuts but
i mean it is nuts that's kind of what
they're going so like they just want to
permanently be able to control whatever
they want by making up random bs
well when they when they look at the way
society is structured they
their world view inherently puts power
dynamics in everything and so they want
to just
blur these distinctions because every
time there's a category that's made
it's not just a category it's it's been
made by someone in power to
oppress some other person or idea or
you know some group of people is being
oppressed right and so
they just want to disrupt all of these
categories all the categories need to be
blurred
they need to be broken apart but why why
create racial segregation
that's the other outcome i'm looking at
if they're saying that you know we're
the
university of michigan dearborn is going
to do a white only cafe event
and then they later apologize it was i'm
sorry it was non-poc
only which it means white only and they
were like i don't know everyone was
welcome but it was for it was for
non-poc to share their non-poc feelings
about how their non-poc community is
being impacted and i'm like
are there like nazis running this with
like a wink wink and a nudge nudge to
their nazi friends
tricking the left into adopting these
things so then we see
the this there's a group of black people
who
got a sponsor they're buying up land in
geor i believe
in georgia near macomb i think it's
pronounced and they want to create a
town called freedom
that is what they describe as pro-black
which for the most part is black only
but they say white people can apply to
live there if they're pro-black
rejected well so i look i was i was
reading the story
actually i find it kind of funny cause
i'm like i can respect the pioneer
attitude
we're gonna go make our own city i'm
like that's awesome you know we don't
have anybody doing that anymore
go do it but but to like racially
segregate i don't know about that
if you found the you know a country like
the us on freedom from religion and good
values like that like that's you know go
go for it but if your foundation is
racial segregation
i mean it's they're literally creating
an ethno state and that's for some
reason
that's not that's not legal is it no i
can't imagine how it would be legal but
the thing is
who's going to step up and say you can't
do this because they already called
i'm going to get all political if joe
biden wins
right right so donald trump bans
critical race theory
right and that's that's the so i guess i
guess the easy way to explain it is like
you could argue that there's a critical
gender theory
gender studies colonial postcolonial
theory
well yeah one of them is critical race
they're like these are the core tenets
of the far left
culture whatever studies trump bans
critical race theory and that is a major
some people have said what like a shot
across the bow like letting him know no
no no way he he straight up took a push
broom and shoved them right out of the
building
and they got really mad about it the
worst part was
when like cnn for instance defended
critical race theory
and white privilege training without
actually knowing what any of it was
yeah i mean you're seeing the the way
they talk about it shift in real time
because
critical race theory is sort of this
obscure thing nobody knows what it is
like there's
i think if you probably look up critical
race three people have just been
googling it non-stop now
but they're trying to reframe it as like
no this is just racial sensitivity
training right
you know this is it's diversity training
it's not the same thing
like it's not a liberal approach towards
racial issues whatsoever it sees race
and everything i mean
robin d'angelo specifically said things
like it's not a question
of whether race is is taking place here
there's a racial issue
it's what is yeah yeah what is the
racial component in there so it's just
a nazi it's this nitpicking with every
situation where you're just gonna start
seeing these phantoms of racism
everywhere because
you're told they're everywhere if you
just squint hard enough and and
do the do the amount of rhetorical work
so that so that's why i feel like
one of their goals might be that listen
if you were
a neo-nazi but a smart one
you know and trying to figure out how to
implement
racial segregation this is exactly what
you would do
there's no other way to do it you come
out waving a nazi flag people are going
to be like get out and they're going to
beat you up
there's that guy in i think portland
walking around wearing a nazi armband
you got punched in the face
yeah like they're not going to let you
do it if you see the list
of what they have with what what they
consider to be white and western
includes things like rationality
i'm going down this list and it's like
who else would agree with everything on
this list that is inherently white
probably every white supremacist no the
white supremacists are nodding their
head feeling like yes
rational thought is an inherently white
thing hard work it's
hard work preparing for the future yeah
for the future this is
this is for them to take that and insist
that this is
somehow white and western i can't even
imagine a more
racist narrative that is gonna one
keep black people from probably wanting
to participate in
in stem in the first place if they're
taught that
going in the academy going to academia
is you know the master's house and i've
seen flyers that have
talked about academia as being the
master's house and we're going to give
you tools to survive
your time in the master's house i think
what are the chances that
someone who wants to be of a black guy
who wants to
to be a scientist and they're getting a
flyer from one of these critical race
theory
uh meetings and it just says here's how
to survive the master's house
are you going to want to go into stem
yeah if you're just if it's
portrayed as a battleground if you're
thinking like oh they're literally
calling it
going on the plantation like maybe i
shouldn't to go into stem because
this is how it's being portrayed or the
or the threats that black conservatives
get the insults the
the cancel culture it's like if you if
like kanye west
was speaking with body armor and he's
crying
talking about you know being pro-life
and and his daughter and abortion all
stuff
and they attack him in the media saying
he's unwell and i'm like dude imagine
how old is that guy do you know how old
kanye's
38 or something 38 yeah 38 38 or so
years you go through your entire life
being told you're not allowed to say
what you believe is true
or else and finally this dude gets the
courage to go up and start saying all
these things and he starts crying and
they attack him for it
i'm not he's 43. i'm not surprised he's
crying
he's like all of these things he's
always wanted to say but they were like
don't say this or else and that's what
they're trying to create
so so i bring this up specifically
because i'm wondering how it is
that this is like this this weird
ideology among the left has creeped in
where
acting quote-unquote white is like a a a
horrible thing you can't do it's a
slight against humanity and then they go
around
claiming that all of these positive
traits which exist in like almost every
other culture
are only white people yeah i mean you
get people like nicole hannah jones that
come out
and they criticize people like kanye on
the basis that
there's this difference here between
being
someone who happens to be black and
someone who's politically black
so kanye isn't even considered capital b
black he's lowercase b
black but he's not capital b black and
if you look at all like the blm
flyers they put out black is always
capitalized and that is just the dead
giveaway that they're talking about
politically black
and not black as the color of your skin
wow
that's amazing i think it's funny that
uh people were bringing up
by poc black indigenous and people of
color
and this is what i was told and you can
let me know if you agree or not
that they created this term specifically
to remove asians because asians are
considered privileged
about that but yeah have you seen the
book in defense of looting
i've seen the cover and i've seen some
some articles written about it
apparently there's a passage and this
was going on i think was it carlin who
tweeted about
this possibly yeah that it said that
jews and
asians are the like um the face of
capital or something like that
oh wow yeah right yeah yeah yeah and so
um i gotta say man when you put out a
book called in defense of looting
it's written by a white person defending
the looting that is destroying the black
community
and you have in it a direct attack on
jews
i gotta wonder dude i really do think
there's probably a bunch of white
supremacists and white nationalists
who have backed away from trump
specifically because they're like whoa
these these people over here giving us
what we want they're the real
anti-semites on this side
yeah do you know sargon of akkad yeah he
did uh
carl benjamin a long time ago he said a
long time ago he said that
the the sjws and the alt-right were like
they completely agree with each other
now they disagree
on like positive and whether it's
positive or negative the different
things
like uh like you might have the
alt-right being racist
you might have the the far left being
racist in a kind of different way
i guess they only disagree on whether or
not white people are good or bad but
they agree on literally everything else
he was like they should work together
because then the the the the far left is
saying you know white people
don't come here go your own space and
the alt-right saying they want that too
that's why i wonder if like the end goal
of the critical race theory stuff is
going to be
racial segregation i mean it's already
happening you're getting this type of
series right what's going on
right i mean you get the richard
spencers of the world
and he wants you know white ethnostate
he might not even have to take steps to
achieve what he wants he can just sit
back and
watch the critical race there's make
their own ethnostate and just absent
themselves in a
day of day of absence or a you know
eternity of absence or something have
you seen the onion article that was like
al qaeda sits back and watches as
america collapses you know like
that that could be it where did the
alt-right go they were so prominent now
they're gone
yeah they're kicking back on the couch
being like we don't got to do anything
in fact speaking out was bad let them do
it
and then there you go and they're going
to exactly more effectively because it's
somehow this is underneath the radar and
no one's standing up for it because it's
just
it's using the right words thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you